what he called me a baby I should have
said that I guess you needed a baby's
help to fix your paper very clever turn
the car around
we're halfway home it's not that clever
why are you being more supportive of me
Sheldon John is a lot of things but he's
not a thief
so you're on his side oh so you're on my
side for the sake of this car ride sure
okay here's the plan
end your relationship with coach Ballard
state dr. Sturgis again get him to love
you more than ever then when he least
expects it break his heart and say
that's for Sheldon great plan you think
so
for the sake of this car ride sure I
need your help reporting an academic
crime sounds serious
yes that's why I'm using my serious
voice but I'll use mine as well what's
going on doctor just has stolen my work
and is using it in his own paper that's
quite the allegation it's not an
allegation it's a fact he was getting a
nervous masses for his neutrinos and I
showed him how to fix it but now he's
refusing to list me as a co-author well
I think he has a point is the he in that
sentence me because that is a strange
way to phrase it no he is him I don't
play games with sentence structure look
I haven't done a forensic examination of
this paper but it's not uncommon to show
you worked or colleague to get their
feedback but I fixed his paper this kind
of accusation could have real
consequences I consider my next steps
very carefully your know-how put me
through to your supervisor please let me
speak to John before you take this any
further
all right but if he calls me a baby feel
free to say then I guess you needed a
baby to fix your paper that's a good one
but I'm not gonna say it hello
how dare you accuse me of plagiarism
this is my reputation you're
jeopardizing well give me the credit I
deserve and I'll stop we've been over
this you made a helpful suggestion and
then you arrogantly assume that it
entitled you to a co-author credit which
it doesn't but I was the one who's your
friend and mentor the idea that I would
steal from you is both personally and
professionally insulting well I'm sorry
you feel that way Sheldon I don't want
to see you in my class anymore